today I thought we would talk a bit
about logical induction paper out of the
machine intelligence Research Institute
very technical paper very mathematical
and can be a bit hard to get your head
around and we're not going to get too
far into it for computer file I just
want to explain like why it's cool and
why it's interesting and people who are
into it can read the paper themselves
and find out about it
the things about logical induction as a
paper is that it's not immediately
obvious why it's in a nice safety paper
but like my perception of the way that
Mary the way to the machine intelligence
Research Institute is thinking about
this is they're saying they're thinking
like we're going to be producing at some
point artificial general intelligence
and as we talked about in previous
videos there are hundreds of ways really
weird subtle difficult to predict ways
that these this kind of thing could go
very badly wrong and so we want to be
confident about the behavior of our
systems before we turn them on and that
means ideally we want to be making
systems that we can actually in the best
case that we could actually prove
theorems about right things that are
well specified enough that we could
actually write down and formally prove
that it will have certain
characteristics and if you look at like
current machine learning stuff older
like deep neural networks and that kind
of thing they're just very opaque do you
mean by that because we don't
necessarily know exactly why it's doing
what it's doing yeah and also just that
the the system itself is very is very
complex and very contingent on a lot of
specifics about the training data and
the architecture and like there's just
yeah effectively we don't understand it
well enough but it's it's like not
formally specified enough I guess and so
they're trying to come up with the sort
of mathematical foundations that we
would need to be able to prove important
things about powerful AI systems before
we were talking about hypothetical
future AI systems we've got time to
print more stamps so maybe it hijacks
the world's stamp printing factories and
when we were talking about the stamp
collector it was really useful to have
this framework of an agent and say this
is what an agent is it's a formally
specified thing and we can reason about
the behavior of agents in general and
then all we need to do is make these
fairly straightforward assumptions about
our AI system that it will behave like
an agent
so we have idealized two forms of
reasoning like we have probability
theory which tells you the rules that
you need to follow to have good beliefs
about the state of the world right and
we have like like rational choice theory
about what what rules you need to follow
and it may not be it may not be like
actually possible to follow those rules
but we can at least formally specify
like if the thing has these properties
it will do this well and all we're
trying to do is they're thinking if
we're building very powerful AI systems
the one thing we can expect from them is
they're going to be able to do thinking
well and so if we can come up with some
formalized method of exactly what we
mean by doing thinking well then if we
do if we reason about that that should
give us some insight into how these
systems will behave that's the idea so
let's talk about probability theory then
this is where we should have a demo
pretty sure backgammon has nice yeah no
this is a fun one how's it - I don't
know how to play backgammon anyway
here's a dime so basic probability
theory right I roll the die now it's
under the cup and I can ask you what's
the probability that that is five one
and six right one in six
because you don't know it could be
anything there was a time when people
reasoned about the probabilities of
things happening in a very sort of fuzzy
way you'd be playing cards and you'd be
like oh you know that card has shown up
here so I guess it's less likely that he
has this hand and people would yeah and
like there was some sense of like
clearly we are doing sort of what we're
doing here is not random it's meaningful
to say that this this outcome or that
outcome is more or less likely by a bit
or by a lot or whatever but people
didn't have a really good explanation of
how that all works until we had
probability theory right we didn't it
was an assistant right right and like
practically speaking you often can't do
the full probability theory stuff in
your head for a game of cards especially
when you are
trying to read people's faces and like
stuff that's very hard to quantify but
now we have this understanding that like
even when we can't actually do it what's
going on underneath is probability
theory so that's one thing right
straightforward probability now let's do
a different thing and now I'm get it now
I'm gonna need a pen now suppose I give
you a sentence that's like the tenth
digit after the decimal point of the
square root of 17 is a 5 what's the
probability that that's true well it's a
much more difficult problem one in 10
right one in 10 seems like a totally
reasonable thing to say right it's gonna
be one of the digits we don't know which
one but if I you've got the paper here
you know you can do like division you
you could do this if you had long enough
like if I gave you say an hour with the
paper and you could sit here and figure
it out and let's say you do it and you
you come up and it seems to be like
three I don't know what it actually is I
haven't done this calculation let's do
the calculation about expression oh I've
don't run way around on 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 it's a 6 oh it's a 6 ok I picked that
out of nowhere so suppose you didn't
have a calculator you were doing it on
paper I gave you you know half an hour
an hour to do the like long division or
whatever is you would have to do to
figure this out what's the probability
this statement is true now what do you
say I'm gonna say zero right but you've
just done this in a big hurry on paper
right you might have screwed up so
what's the probability that you made a
mistake you forgot to like carry the 1
or something so it could be 1 so it's
not 0 this yeah there's like some
smaller probability and then if I left
you in in the room again still with the
piece of paper for 100 years a thousand
years infinite time eventually assuming
that was correct eventually you say 0
right you come up with some like formal
proof that this is this is false whereas
you imagine if I leave you for infinite
time with the cup and you can't look at
it
you can't look under the cup it's 1/6
then it's gonna stay 1/6 forever right
when you're playing cards you've got
these probabilities for which cards you
think depending on the game
and as you observe new things you're
updating your probabilities for these
different things as you observe new
evidence and then it maybe eventually
you'll actually see the thing and then
you can go to 100% or zero whereas in
this case all that's changing is your
thinking
but you're doing a similar sort of thing
you are still updating your
probabilities for things but probability
theory kind of doesn't have anything to
say about this scenario like probability
is how you update when you see new
evidence and here you're not seeing any
new evidence
so in principle whatever the probability
of this is it's one or at zero just as a
direct logical consequence of things
that you already know right so your
uncertainty comes from the fact that you
are not logically on this yet in order
for you to figure things out it takes
you time and this turns out to be really
important because it's so most of the
time what you have is actually kind of a
mixture of these types of uncertainty
right so let's imagine a third scenario
right
suppose you were like an AI system and
that's your eyes because you have a
camera I do the same thing again and now
I ask you what's the probability that
it's a five you would say one sake
because you don't know but on the other
hand you have recorded video footage of
it going under the thing the video is
your memory of what happened right so
you're not observing new information
you're still observing the same thing
you observed the first time but you can
look at that and say hmm you know it
looked like it with the amount of energy
it had and the way that it was rotating
and which numbers were where it looked
like it probably wasn't going to land on
a 5 if I asked you on a millisecond
deadline you know what what was it
what's the probability that it was a 5
you're going to give the same number
that you gave at the beginning here
right 1 in 6 but you can look at the
data you already have the information
the observations that you've already
made and you can do logical reasoning
about them you can think okay based on
the speed it was going the angle it was
turned out on which which pieces which
faces were where and so on it seems like
you know maybe you can run some
simulations internally something like
that say it seems like actually less
likely than one in six right if before I
thought it was like 0.16 recurring now I
think it's like 0.15 because all of my
grand a million simulations and it seems
like that the longer you think about it
the more precise you can be maybe you
keep thinking about it again and you get
it down to like you think it's actually
0.13 right something like that but you
don't you can't you don't actually know
right because there's still things you
don't know like you don't know exactly
the physical properties of the paper or
what exactly the inside of the cup is
like or the weighting of the dye like
you still have uncertainty left because
you haven't seen which way it landed but
by doing some thinking you're able to
take some of your you're able to like
reduce your logical uncertainty the
point is that probability theory in
order to do probability theory properly
to modify your beliefs according to the
evidence you observe in a way that
satisfies the the laws of probability
you have to be logically omniscient you
have to be able to immediately see all
of the logical consequences of
everything you observe and propagate
them throughout your beliefs and this is
like not really practical in the real
world like in the real world
observations do not form an orderly
queue and come at you one at a time and
give you enough time after each one to
fully integrate the consequences of each
observation because human beings are
bounded right we have limited processing
ability and limited speed with this kind
of logical uncertainty
it feels very intuitive that we can do
probabilities based on our logical
uncertainty that we can we can think
about it in this way it makes perfect
sense to say that 1 in 10 is the
probability until you've done your
thinking one in 10 seems like a
perfectly reasonable number but like why
is one
a good answer and like 50% is not a good
answer because you might look at it and
say well this is a logical statement
it's either true or false that's two
possibilities you know 50% why why is
one in ten more sensible and in fact you
had to do a bit of thinking to get there
right you had to say oh yeah it's going
to be some digit there are 10 digits I
don't have any reason to prefer one
digit over the other so 10% so you are
like always doing reasoning to come up
with these probabilities but the thing
is that according to standard
probability theory this is like kind of
a nonsense question because if you
imagine like from the perspective of
probability theory this kind of
statement is equivalent to saying what's
the probability that one equals one
right or what's the probability that
like true equals false they're all just
it's just a logical statement it doesn't
have a probability it just is true but
if you can't think infinitely fast then
you need to have answers you need to
have estimates it estimates you need to
have estimates of your answers before
you've thought for infinite time about
them this is like an important thing for
actually getting by in the world because
as I say like the observations don't
just line up and wait for you to reason
all of their consequences through so
when it comes to empirical uncertainty
we have probability theory which has
these axioms and these are these sort of
the rules that you need to follow in
order to do probability well and they're
sort of things like that probabilities
can't be negative they have to be
between 0 and 1 the if you have a set of
mutually exclusive possibilities and
that that constitutes everything that
can happen then they all need to add up
to 1 and then if you're if you're doing
probabilities about like logical
sentences then there's all these extra
rules that make perfect sense like you
have statement a and statement B you
also have statement a and B then
statement a and B has to be less likely
than
A or B or the same it could be the same
but like if a has twenty percent chance
of happening then a and B couldn't
possibly have more than twenty percent
chance of happening right
even if B is guaranteed to happen it
can't so that's like a rule if you find
in you're doing your probabilities you
have a and B that has a higher
probability than either A or B and
you've made a mistake that kind of thing
you have these rules it would be nice if
we could find some way of doing of
dealing with logical uncertainty some
some similar set of rules that is useful
and so um and so related to that we have
these things like like Dutch book
arguments which are about I don't know
why they called Dutch I feel like the
English language just like is so harsh
to the Dutch for no reason
unjustly maligned but anyway we're like
if you if basically there's there's
theorems which which you can prove that
if your beliefs don't obey these rules
then there will exist some set of bets
by which you're guaranteed to lose money
some some set of bets that you will
happily take by looking at your
probabilities that you cut you can't
possibly win whatever happens you lose
money and that seems like a stupid like
you don't want that in your beliefs so
that's like an argument that says that
your beliefs should obey these rules
because if they do you're at least never
gonna end up in a situation where you're
guaranteed to lose by betting and that's
like one of the things we want beliefs
for we want some kind of equivalent
thing for logical uncertainty and that's
what this paper is trying to do it's
trying to come up with a rule so yeah
you could you could say if if you are
doing your probability theory stuff in
such a way that there are no Dutch books
that can be made against you then that's
good and you're doing well and so when
we're talking about advanced AI systems
we're gonna it's like a good assumption
to make that they're at least gonna try
to not have any Dutch books against them
in the way they do
probability so they will probably be a
banging probability theory and it would
be nice if we had some equivalent thing
for logical uncertainty that said if you
are satisfying this criteria and in the
way that you do this then you're not
going to be like doing obviously stupid
things and that's what this paper is
trying to do when you're talking about
probability there's you can kind of
think about what properties you would
want your system of deciding
probabilities to have people have
written down various things they would
want from this system right there would
be a system of like assigning
probabilities to statements logical
statements in and then being able to
like update those over time so one thing
you would want is you would want it to
converge which just means if you're
thinking about a logical statement you
might think of something that makes it
seem more likely and then think of
something else like I know actually it's
less it should be less likely and
whatever you can imagine some systems
for some statements would just think
forever and constantly be changing what
they think and never make their mind up
that's no good right we want a system
that if you give it infinite time to
think will eventually actually decide
one of things so that's one thing you
wanted to converge secondly you
obviously want it to converge like to
good values so if something turns out to
be provable within the system that it's
using then you would want it to
eventually converge to one if something
turns out to be disprovable you want it
to eventually converge to zero and then
the rest of the time you want it to be
like well calibrated which means if you
take all of the things that it ever
thought were 80% likely to be true of
those about 80 percent should actually
end up being true right it should when
it gives you an estimate of the
probability that should be right in some
sense another one is that it should
never and this one's like a bit
controversial but it seems reasonable to
me that it should never assign
probability 1 to something which is not
proved or that can't be proved and it
should never assign probability 0 to
something that can't be disproved they
call that non dogmatism at the end of
all of this again at infinity after
thinking forever
probabilities that it gives two things
should follow the rules of probability
right the ones we talked about before
those rules right it should at the end
of it you should end up with like a
valid probability distribution over all
of your stuff their criterion that
they've come up with which is the
equivalent of there are no Dutch books
is based on this algorithm that they've
made which satisfies this criterion and
therefore has a whole bunch of these
nice properties that you would want a
logical inductor to have so the way the
algorithm works is it's one of those
Aeneas tale rhythms I've ever seen it is
it's weird and wonderful and if you're
if you're a person who is interested in
interesting algorithms I would really
recommend checking out the paper it's
very technical because we don't have
time in this video and I may go into it
deeper on my channel at some point if I
ever come to actually understand it
which to be honest I don't fully right
now but it's based around the idea of a
prediction market which is a super cool
thing that's worth explaining
in financial markets as they currently
exist you can have futures right and a
future it's futures contract it's a
contract which says I promised to sell
you this amount of stuff at this price
of a particular thing right so you say
take a date a year from now and you say
I'm gonna sell you this many gallons of
jet fuel for this price at least that's
the way it used to be done in practice
the actual jet fuel doesn't move if you
just go by the price of jet fuel and you
pay the equivalent as if you had and
then they can go and buy the jet fuel
themselves but this is like a really
useful financial instrument to have
because is let's say you run an airline
your main cost is jet fuel prices are
very volatile if prices go up you could
just go under completely so you say okay
I'm going to buy a whole bunch of these
jet fuel futures and then if the price
goes up I'm gonna have to pay loads more
for jet fuel but I'll make a load of
money on these contracts and it if you
do it right it exactly balances out the
cost of that is if the price of jet fuel
falls through the floor
then you don't get to save money because
you're saving money on jet fuel but then
you're losing all this money on the
contracts so it just sort of like
balances out your risk lets you lock in
the price that you're gonna pay a year
in advance and that's just like super
useful for all sorts of businesses
really really good in agriculture as
well because you don't know what your
yield is going to be in so um so the
point is that the price that you can buy
these contracts for has to be a really
good prediction of what the price of jet
fuel is going to be at the time when the
contract ends and you can kind of treat
the price of that as a combination of
everybody's best estimate because if you
can predict the price of jet fuel a year
in advance better than anybody else you
can make like almost arbitrary amounts
of money doing that and in doing so you
bring the price to be a more accurate
representation right if you think the
price is too low and it's gonna be more
then you're gonna buy a bunch and when
you buy it that raises the price of it
because you know supply and demand so
these prices end up representing
humanity's best estimate of the price of
jet fuel year from now but the thing
that's cool is you could build a bit
like this is just a piece of paper with
stuff written on it right and these days
it's not even a piece of paper in
principle you can write anything on
there right so what if you wrote a
contract that said I promise to pay a
hundred pounds if such-and-such horse
wins the Grand National and zero
otherwise
and then that's on the market and people
can buy and sell it right so if this
horse is like guaranteed to win the
grand national then this contract is
effectively a hundred pound note right
it's it's a sure it's money in the bank
as if why is that a phrase banks banks
aren't that reliable but anyway if the
horse is like guaranteed to lose then
it's worth zero and if the horse has a
fifty percent chance of winning that
thing is going to trade for fifty pounds
and so by making these contracts and
allowing people to trade them you can
get these good like unbiased and as
accurate as you can hope for predictions
of future events
and that's what prediction markets are
for you can make money on them by being
good at predicting stuff and anybody
else can just look at the prices things
are trading at and just directly convert
them into probabilities and that's you
know in a spherical chickens in a vacuum
kind of way
obviously in practice there's various
things that can go wrong but like in
principle this is a really beautiful way
of effectively doing distributed
computing where you have everybody is
doing their own computation and then
you're aggregating them using the price
mechanism as communication between your
different nodes in you
yeah like super cool so that's what
logical induction does it like simulates
a prediction market where all of the
contracts are a logical statement I
think in this way it's not a hundred
dollars it's it's one dollar so if it's
trading at one dollar then it's for sure
it's it's certain saying you know this
is currently trading at sixty cents and
I think it's more more than sixty
percent likely to be true so I'll buy
some and that seems like a good
investment and so all of the traders in
the algorithm are programs they're
computer programs and it turns out that
if you run this and this is computable
it's not like tractable in a practical
sense because you're running vast
numbers of like arbitrary programs but
it is in principle computable it ends up
having the market it's as a whole ends
up having ends up satisfying all of
these really nice properties is that
because it comes into balance yeah as
their as the traders trade with each
other the ones who are like good at
predicting end up making more money and
the ones who are bad at predicting like
go bankrupt effectively you might
imagine some trader in this system which
is a program that just goes around
looking for situations in which you have
a and B and also a and B in the system
and the prices don't work and it's like
arbitrage right so and there are people
who do this currently on the stock mark
there's different things you can do
where you can say oh you know anytime
the anytime the price is different
between two markets you can make money
by buying in one and selling in the
other and stuff like that you can do
arbitrage and it's the same kind of
thing you can have so some of these
programs will get rich by just saying oh
I notice that this statement for a and B
has a probability that's actually higher
than the probability of B so I'm gonna
sell that you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
buy some beet array so you know I'm
gonna like respond to that in a way that
makes me money and because there's all
of these traders they will they will
eventually cause everything to line up
right and so the thing will converge
this is the equivalent of saying there's
no Dutch book for your probabilities the
logical induction criterion the market
satisfies it if there's no efficiently
computable trader that can exploit the
market which means that it can like find
a reliable strategy for making loads of
money without risk as long as you have
that then it satisfies the logical
induction criterion which then means you
get all of these other properties for
free some of the properties that that it
has are kind of crazy like it's okay
with self-reference
it like doesn't care about paradoxes
there's all kinds of really cool things
that that don't trip it up bringing us
back to what we started talking about
how does the paper relate to the a Oh
safety thing right right so what we're
trying to do reasoning and possibly
prove theorems about very powerful AI
systems and that means that we want to
be able to think of them just in terms
of being good at thinking and we've got
a lot of good theory that pins down like
what does it mean to be good at
empirical uncertainty we have all of
probability theory and like statistics
and we can we can say these are the
things you need to do to be good at
probability and we have like rational
choice theory and we can say this is
what it means to be good at making
decisions and so then when we're
reasoning about AI systems we can think
well it's probably going to be good at
reasoning about answer
making decisions but we have to also
assume that a very powerful hypothetical
future AI system would be good at
reasoning under logical uncertainty
because it's going to be a physical like
bounded system it is going to need time
to think about things and it probably is
going to need to like make decisions
based on things that it hasn't logically
thought through every possible
consequence off yet so it's probably
going to be good at this too and we need
some like formal framework with which we
can think about what it means to be good
at reasoning about logical uncertainty
and that's like what this paper is
trying to do there erasable yeah okay I
do also have I had sharpies yeah I do
have sharpies yeah they squeak on the
paper people don't like okay fair enough
in fact all pens do but these are
slightly better right friction